[Music]
christian and i were at the prairie
whale in the berkshires in great
barrington shout out they have one
bathroom which was troublesome for me
one day because when i went in there uh
somebody had just come out they had
polluted
let's say what do you mean
they had um
they left stuff in there yes well they
hadn't left it in their
they had permanently no they left the
vapors of the thing in there i
understand that's just saying that and
is that grosser than just saying they
it's one of the grossest things i've
ever heard
poo papers normally in that situation i
will hold it but this was more of an
emergency and there's nobody else
waiting so i felt like okay i'm gonna
run in and repeat was yours a one
another one emergency definitely a one
okay and when i came out a
very nice lady was waiting
to use the bathroom and i felt the need
to tell her that the odor that she was
going to experience wasn't i wasn't the
result of that i hadn't it wasn't your
product no it wasn't i've made products
in the past but i would never she you
didn't have to tell her that part of it
though no she probably assumed that but
i did tell her that i wasn't responsible
and in doing so i think i sounded guilty
i think it was protesting as jake's
perspective it's ironic that now you're
sounding guilty recounting the story
exactly i i well we talk about this
today and it relates to what we're going
to get into today on the episode so
let's get into it life could be a dream
life could be a dream
you're listening to life is short i'm
your host justin long life could be a
dream sweetheart
[Music]
and with me as always is my equally um
odor producing i knew you would say that
you've i mean we've all we all have we
all do it we all do it we all do it and
there's no shame and yet i do have shame
also everyone's been in that position i
would guess at some point in their life
you know when you go to a public
bathroom
and you come out and you you're not
responsible for that
what's in there and people think you are
i feel like that's happened to everybody
it happened to me again when i was
working in atlanta recently where i i
chose option the other option which is
to just not go in i held it for the ride
home because um it was so horrific that
i and i'm not as you can hear i'm not
good at explaining that it wasn't well
let me ask you this if something is that
offensive to you
what is a bigger deterrent going in
there yourself
or
being blamed for the smell once you come
out being blamed that's worse really
going in especially now we have masks
the masks don't uh remove the odor not
all of it's teaching your nostrils they
do some of it do you think oh i'm sure
yeah i think it's that it's just a shame
of like having been because it's also a
rude thing it's just rude of course like
gross and why would you do but like
sometimes you can't i know you can't
help can't help but i know i know i know
and so i should be very judgmental of
you i should be more respectful of that
but it was um this was an instance where
and i'm sure she and she said something
like when i after i explained it she was
like sure you know she may have just
been playful
but she also may have and even if she
thinks i probably didn't do it i knew
and i could see her the rest of the meal
because she was sitting there near us
there i could see she kept kind of
looking over i could tell there was
definitely a seat of doubt well and also
not to like oh boohoo i'm famous but
there is when you're a known person
there's an added problem with it where
if that happens to you
this woman conceivably could go on
instagram and be like oh justin
i know left a really foul odor in this
bathroom and then and that that's a
story and then it becomes like a thing
that people laugh about so why are we
talking about
being falsely goose or something
wrongful accusations
well um in a very glib playful way that
happened to me once that happened to all
of us and
today our guest
well because it happened in a much more
severe much more dramatic life-altering
way
to our guest today our guest is amanda
knox
you've all heard of her you all might
not know
uh her story as well as we now do as
well as you will once you listen to this
episode but um she was somebody that i
was aware of for years she was a fixture
in
like tabloid news news in general she
was infamous yes yeah free for a long
time our first infamous guest i would
say yeah
right i'm just trying to think
she who else rose to infamy she was
accused of
committing a horrific crime murder
in italy when she was a student when she
was an exchange student in italy and
it uh became a massive
media sensation
and
understandably because it was this girl
you know this well he got into this very
um and she was pretty and she was
privileged and she was
all of these things that we think put
white and yet uh she got wrapped up in
this in this very
gruesome murder and
we it was fascinating talking to her i'm
now i've been trying to think if we've
had any infamous guests and i know we've
have guests who have like toyed with
infamous infamy they've had degrees of
information but mostly they're just
but but she's a person
she's person who's famous um
not by choice at all she did not choose
to become famous but she became very
famous
and uh her story is harrowing and
there's a great documentary on netflix
about it which we saw before um before
justin talked were called it's just
called amanda knox and it is
fascinating and tragic yeah what she had
what she went through and she was
falsely accused of this horrible crime
and
um but now she's made it out on the
other side and she's older now and she
has a career and a husband and a podcast
great new podcast podcast called
labyrinths that she
hosts with her husband and she has
some really interesting guests like
malcolm gladwell and andrew yang and
so she's uh she's lived to tell her
story yeah she's come out um the other
side she's come out uh
glowing really and
uh we will get into her whole story it's
fascinating the ins and outs um but i
would i think it's helpful if you don't
know much about her if you
if you were like me before i i did any
research and you just thought oh
i know of her and she's associated with
this crime and maybe she did the crime
um i would strongly recommend like
christian said watching this documentary
this netflix show it's uh
not long an hour and a half two hours
and um just to get some backstory
because we do get in into the
weeds of what happened to her but i
think it would help to have some context
some more context so anyway uh obviously
up to you
i'm not going to tell you what to do i
would just hope that you listen to the
remainder of the show at some point and
this isn't an ad for netflix i'm also
not begging you you know i'm not
desperate for you but it would be nice
if you did you're listening now can i
hear it now yeah can i hear the
interview sure let's do it okay yeah um
this is my
i would say
you know she's also listening to the
show which is very nice she does yeah so
she's not only infamous but she is a um
shorty i know she's technically a shorty
but she's likes the show so which is
well we talk about it we talk about how
she likes the show i can't wait to hear
that yes
and her crime of course the crime that
she did not commit you'll hear all about
it uh when i talk right now to amanda
knox
life could be a dream sweetheart
[Music]
when you were going through this ordeal
i was so aware of you of your name and
of the this thing that was happening and
um
uh even though i didn't
make any effort to read about it that's
how huge a story it was what was your
perception of how big it had gotten how
out in the zeitgeist like uh would you
see news articles where would people
from the outside share anything of that
with you during the time that it was
happening i was very insulated from it i
mean like literally i was in a prison
cell and i only had access to so many
channels that were available
inside the prison
my focus was not as much on the media
attention about this case my focus was
on the courtroom and it was the problem
of my family to have to deal with this
sort of onslaught of media attention
wherever they went whether that was
people who were here in the united
states reaching out to them or anytime
they came to visit me there was like an
onslaught of journalists who were there
while they were trying to go from their
car into the prison to co-visit me so
like that was a whole thing that they
had to deal with
in the meantime
i'm dealing with prison like that's what
i'm dealing with
right what is that like i mean can you
even is that way too big of a question
what what are the first what are the
memories that you that really stand out
that you you're like oh thank god i'm
not there anymore
oh god uh so many memories um
yeah so
all right so to give a description of
some of the scenarios that i found
myself in so
one thing that was really big for me
that was a coping mechanism was i i read
voraciously i was very much
consuming um or practicing a kind of
escapism through
reading a lot and i often just would
plug um you know
stuff in my ears to not have to hear
everyone yelling or do you know doing
whatever with prison sounds and i would
just sit there for hours and hours and
hours on my bed reading um and actually
one of my favorite books that i read
while i was in there was the
hitchhiker's guide to the galaxy
because i just wanted something fun and
uplifting because my whole new like
normal default setting was sadness like
i've always been um
you know a a kind of upbeat person and
like great you know nothing bad ever
happened to me in life so why would i
ever feel depressed or whatever like and
i've always been super positive and then
i get into an environment where
i am exposed to a lot of very sad broken
um hurt people would they target you
ever i mean with those
how vulnerable were you to people
because you were famous in there or
infamous and yes
yeah i was the famous prisoner
um because everyone was talking about my
case everyone had an opinion about it
everyone wanted to talk to me about it
um and i very early on learned to not
talk to people about it because that i
just it wasn't worth it and i i it also
like i didn't feel better
just sitting around stewing about it the
entire time i tried to like spend my
uh mental energy thinking like how can i
make today worth living um so
but it must be inescapable i mean or
what or was it could you escape it like
are there times where you're having to
socialize with other inmates and they're
like it's still a man that tells me
[Laughter]
nice nice accent
um yeah so i um so there's no like way
to not be involved in the prison
community right like you are a part of a
community that is very small and tight
like close-knit i wasn't in like this
huge prison that had hundreds and
hundreds of prisoners i think at
maximum capacity
the female prison that i was in the one
building that we had had 90 people in it
when i first went in there it maybe had
30 people in it and then there was this
sort of swelling i got to know a lot of
people very well um in so far as i had
to
so i very much stayed
to myself for my own protection because
i didn't want my own sort of personal
feelings or experiences to become the
gossip or the fodder that we sort of we
didn't have a lot to go on so like that
sort of interpersonal dynamics became
this really big
sort of issue of everyone's interested
in so what i did who's talking to those
shady reporters i mean some of those
guys i saw the netflix documentary last
night and that one guy nick
pisa
what a piece of p p piece of [ __ ] i mean
yeah that's what my family called him
nick pisa [ __ ] oh i like him i want to
talk about your family too because they
seem they seem impressive too in their
their own right um
so you are not wanting to engage a lot
with the prison population yes how do
you
keep from doing that how do you keep to
yourself in that environment well what
you do is you instead offer what you are
willing to participate in the prison
community so i found out pretty early on
that i was one of the only literate
people in the prison environment because
this was a you know
most of the prisoners were not actually
italian at all
um they were very very very very poor
people from other countries um a lot of
them didn't even speak italian so it as
soon as i became fluent in italian i
started being everyone i started being
the unofficial translator of the prison
for a lot of these women who are coming
from nigeria
um
and for those who were italian and in
prison we're talking like the poorest of
the poor
who also were
not very well educated and like i could
speak better italian than they could um
so it was a really interesting
environment where
i was writing people's letters for them
i was reading their court documents for
them i was helping oh my god you were
like andy dufresne andy dufresne
from shawshank oh okay
yeah that's my only touchstone for
prison life is yeah the only thing i
remember from that film because it's a
bit traumatic for me to watch is the um
going through the poop part
yes and yeah you didn't have to do that
no but i totally would have if it was
required like if that was the only way
right i would go down the poop drain
like without a doubt you wrote such a
nice letter thank you for that it was i
my brother read it to me last night
in which you say that you're open to
talking about everything but um
you know that's good to hear because i
otherwise i i probably tiptoe around a
lot of this stuff in an effort to not
trigger you what how are you very nice
of you because some people
aren't as
considerate
i'm not i'm not i'm i'm trying not to be
like nick pisa
yeah my goal in life um
how do you talk about it without um it
conjuring
difficult memories um well there's no
way to talk about it that doesn't
conjure difficult memories
um i think it's just
how like it's the way that i am asked to
talk about the worst experience of my
life and this is like a huge thing for
me because i think that coming home from
this experience and
you know having people
treat me like this sort of object of
intrigue and entertainment and
and having my worst experience in my
life be the object of that intrigue and
inner talk
god i can't imagine
like that that is that sort of has
raised my awareness of how like i see it
happening to other people
the way that i
deal with it and i find out very quickly
if if someone's you know a considerate
person or not is whether or not i feel
like they are
pushing me
to talk about what i went through
for their own sake instead of like for
my sake so when someone stops me at you
know
a bus terminal and is like oh my god i
really want to talk about with you about
your interrogation and i'm like well
actually i'm just like on my way to the
grocery store i i don't want to talk to
you random stranger about my
interrogation like some people will i've
had people like who i was you know
buying a ticket from somebody like hold
on to my credit card until i answered
their questions
and so like that is horrible
well because of course you were offered
up it to the world as this like you said
this object of intrigue and um and you
become then a commodity but but whereas
i i've heard from a lot of actors who
you know go through moments of like oh
man dealing with fame
there are moments of annoyance or
whatever but they
in a way asked for it you you and it's
about something that's inherently kind
of fun and good they're in movies or
whatever yeah but you this is that
you're right this is like all the result
of this
horrific experience that you had to
navigate i i i can't imagine what that
means
i actually have a lot of sympathy for
celebrities because i don't think that
anyone who
has become a professional actor
has
actually
signed up
for their personal life to be
consumed by
people as entertainment i don't either
but i can understand that perception
that it may have or at least it's easier
to for me to understand that but for in
your case you
weren't doing anything remotely public
or
yeah you know that
you weren't in any way subject to that
kind of scrutiny um
it just happened to be this really
horrible coincidence that um yeah that
you can go from like a private person to
a public figure overnight
i literally did nothing
to
do that like i things happened to me
and then i became a public figure and
then suddenly all of my rights as a
public citizen or as a private citizen
go out the window because now it's in
the public interest to know what my sex
life is all about oh my god
yeah that's interesting that like you
know all of these sort of
rights that we think that we have
can go out the window in a second
if if somehow the world like
not even you not even you cross a line
yeah the circumstances just inspire
against you yeah
yeah i mean i that that's what i found
most intriguing and you say that it's a
great way to start this documentary um
the netflix documentary where you say
either i'm this monster i'm this
you know sociopathic psychopathic
monster who did this thing or i'm just
like you and um
and that's what i think is so compelling
about what happened to you because
your testament to the fact that it could
really happen to anyone yeah
yeah i think a lot of people sort of
feel a little more comfortable with the
idea that it only happens to like poor
people and it only happens to like young
black men and it's like well it does
happen to them a lot yes it doesn't mean
that we don't have a system that's sort
of
set up to allow for such a thing
um and that we don't have a media that's
uh set up to
cons like to sort of build upon and and
profit upon
these sorts of
stories
yes that's
that was another fascinating part of it
how the the spin the spin and the press
so much of it was had had like really uh
overt misogyny and um
are you at a place where you
can let go of
some of that anger because i imagine
there was a considerable amount of anger
and frustration because they took so
much of your time
we talk about that a lot on the show how
precious time is and that's the thing
that really struck me about
you know every time you'd have to go
through another appeal and you'd lose a
case it was like a year later a year and
i think about a year especially like now
we can all kind of like quantify it in
this way like collectively that it's
been a year that we've all been in this
situation it's pandemic you probably
don't want to give them any more time
you know any more energy there's that
and i think that's pretty uh universal
with a lot of um wrongfully convicted
people i found that that's pretty common
where it's like well i was sitting in my
prison cell i literally just can't be
mad
all day every day i kind of have to
still like do my daily rhythms in the
same way that we're all in this pandemic
and we can't all be sad about being in
this pandemic the entire time we also
have to do our jobs and and have our
relationships and make the best of
what is a new normal adapt to it adapt
to a reality and it may be an unpleasant
reality and we may then be touched by
that i spent years of my life
feeling like i couldn't plant roots and
that i didn't have a future
and i was very very just like on my toes
waiting to react to the next sort of
thing that would hit me instead of
living a proactive life and imagining oh
you know i wonder what i'm gonna be you
know five or ten years from now like i
was never able to make plans like that
during my entire twenties
because i was on trial because i'm mad
on your behalf
it's impossible to answer but i wonder
what and i'm sure you've
wondered this what you would what you
would be doing
you know the type of people the circles
you'd be running and how different your
life might be it's well and what's
really sad is or at least what my
husband thinks is really sad is
i occasionally i'm like
i don't know if you would love me um if
it weren't for like me having been
put through this experience that made me
mature really quickly and me yeah yeah
question all of these assumptions that i
had about how the world worked like
suddenly i live in this very sort of
intellectual meta space because i was
forced to sort of right it's like what
he said it strips away all the exit the
extra stuff all that
and it and it it forces you to examine
your truth yeah it trims the fat and it
yes
and also probably literally
it did actually
that was a little bit uncomfortable
where at time like i lost so much weight
in prison and occasionally like people
would be like oh man we should go on the
amanda knox diet because she's looking
great oh my god my hair's falling out
oh my god well one of the grossest parts
of the documentary was when um some
journalists i hesitate to call him a
journalist some journalist was like um
oh is she uh she's not wearing makeup do
they they talk about how you're like you
look like you could use some makeup or
something and i think it was shepherd
smith correct me if i'm wrong i i don't
know i uh and and that to me was like
god this is what it it revealed a real
ugliness about um a lot of aspects of
our media and our society our our our
need for for sensationalist like gossip
and that kind of fodder and their weird
expectations of who ends up in front of
the camera and like what context it's
like
why would you ever think if i'm coming
from a prison cell that i'm gonna be
have my hair blown out like what are you
thinking
the amount of expectations with somebody
like you i can't imagine i i
and again not that like you're right
actress don't sign up for this but like
well for this podcast for example i have
no real right to to say to people well
you don't know me because like the truth
is they kind of do because i'm just sort
of like
myself on this and i try to be in
interviews and stuff but um
in this case it's like they're seeing
something through the lens of of a very
specific
horrible thing that you went through i
and they have all these preconceived
notions it must be
really off-putting it must be really
unsettling for you well what's beautiful
about what i found about the podcast
experience experiences here you are like
having the opportunity to be yourself
like you're you're not being a character
you're being yourself you're expressing
your ideas you're having conversations
with people that are revealing an aspect
of who you are but it's still your
choice right like so when i'm working on
episodes of my podcast i go
i'm going to choose to talk about this
and i'm also going to choose to like
talk about how my own experience has
informed my ideas about this oh it must
be so liberating yeah it's so liberating
for you to do that yeah and therapeutic
relate
like the thing that i love about
podcasts is having the opportunity to
sit across from someone and go we have
no reason to be like to relate to each
other or have empathy for each other but
we do
because all of these experiences
are echoes of each other
right and we can i think that's why i
was so compelled by your story because
there's um i can in a much different
tinier way relate to aspects of it
relate to false accusations and people
saying things about me and and people
having a perception of me um
there's still people i'm sure people in
italy people wherever that think you did
this thing yeah i mean on the one hand i
i'm always trying to put myself in the
shoes of
the people who think those kinds of
things because i genuinely actually want
to understand why
and a part of me finds it very easy to
understand why because
if you have not
invested a ton of time and energy to dig
into the facts of the case then the only
thing that you've had access and
exposure to is
the most salacious headlines that made
it
into your sort of
awareness space that made it to the top
of your facebook feed so if that's the
only thing that you've ever been exposed
to then of course you're going to think
that like of course you're going to
think that i'm a shady character or that
i probably did something but who knows
something yeah
like right i guess because you absorb
enough of that and it's and it's out
there enough that your name is
associated with this horrific thing
enough even if it's like
you know
if it's a question as to whether you did
or whatever it is if you're associated
with this horrible thing that's got to
stick and and that must be
i can't imagine what that must be like
well and what's frustrating is so i
don't actually fault people for having
those kinds of misconceptions what i do
fault
is the
the way that the media is allowed
to sort of say well you know we're just
putting it out there um people can
decide for themselves but what they do
put out there is the thing that is going
to get them the most clicks and so
the you know the nuanced complicated
analysis of all the facts the case is
not going to get as much clicks as you
won't believe what amanda knox's you
know
and that nick pisa again not to make it
about him but he he more or less said
that he said you know i mean this is
what it's about this is the game this is
like what um
oh god i can't stand that guy um
in talking to strangers uh the malcolm
gladwell book he he says that your
reaction um to meredith's murder that's
what led to the italians falsely
accusing you who's and thinking you were
guilty
how do you now like in the
in this whole different context how do
you explain that reaction i'm sure
you've thought about it a lot i'm sure
you've talked to gladwell about it is
there a part of you that like
kind of understands the italians for
making this assumption and it's funny i
have a whole podcast episode about this
oh i can't wait to do it so in the
podcast we should say it's called
labyrinths yes and this is the one you
do with your husband so
you have an episode about malcolm
gladwell yes so i interviewed malcolm
gladwell
and i discussed his chapter um in
talking to strangers about my case um
such a good book yeah it's a great book
um but i also think that he was kind of
wrong
oh
which is interesting because like i
wouldn't have said that say
you know as soon as i got out like i had
very much sort of internalized the sense
of it must have been something about me
why else would there be this focus on me
i like i must have done something weird
or i must have looked the wrong way
and what i have discovered by meeting
other wrongfully convicted people
is it's actually
not
as much about
the person and whether how they acted
but it's about the people who genuinely
have agency in the in the equation so is
it is it
my fault that
the
you know the cops who originally made a
judgment about me and and whether or not
i was acting appropriately
decided to always sort of focus their
attention
on moments when i wasn't crying or i was
saying i'm hungry i need some pizza and
they were like well a real you know
friend wouldn't would be so distraught
they wouldn't want to eat pizza oh my
god the leaps that they're making
especially the guy that fetishized
sherlock holmes i mean with the pipe and
like he was so clearly that's the other
thing so many of these men were driven
by ego and uh and needing to they
already had a narrative of what happened
they just needed to
to help create it um but yeah the leaps
that they would take like the fact that
she was
uh you know looking to the left means
that she was lying or these uh
that was infuriating too i reacted to
the whole situation in a lot of ways
sometimes i was crying sometimes i was
not crying sometimes i was getting
comforted by my boyfriend sometimes i
was just sitting there alone and what
gets remembered and reported is what
allows for the narrative to make sense
it's just retroactive justification
uh yes and i think that that happens
over and over and over again that once
the lens of suspicion is cast upon you
anything you do can look suspicious
under a certain light
in the early 2000s millions of
households across the world tuned in to
watch contestants battle for the last
rose or to be the final survivor on the
island reality tv was beginning to
dominate the airwaves and every show
needed to be bigger flashier more
scandalous than the last but in the case
of one infamous dating show the real
drama was happening off-screen and it
would shape the future of reality tv the
reality tv series there's something
about miriam seemed like a pretty
standard dating competition six young
men vibed for the affection of miriam
rivera a beautiful model from mexico but
when miriam revealed that she was a
trans woman during the show's finale the
on-screen drama sparked an international
uproar about gender sexuality and
whether reality television had finally
gone too far follow harsh reality the
story of miriam rivera on apple podcasts
amazon music or you can listen early and
add free by joining wondering plus in
apple podcasts or the wondery app
[Music]
hello hello
it again 2007 so i i was thinking too
like how different that case would be
you're talking about these other people
who were wrongfully
imprisoned and have gone through similar
experiences and and oftentimes they make
movies about them i mean i'm thinking of
like steven avery or you know i think
that's why these things are so
compelling because it is a such a
miscarriage of justice and these these
authority figures are abusing their
authority and their power um but but now
there's it's easier to kind of shine a
light on on these stories it's easier to
amplify them there are hashtags but that
was before all that was before social
media really
how different do you think your case
would be
um if it happened today and
with with social media like what what
what could you do differently
oh gosh um
so we're imagining that today i'm 20
years old and i still have the sort of
same frames of reference
about
authority figures that i can trust
without question
well see that's hard to answer right
because you don't i mean it's yeah yeah
yeah it's a whole different world what i
have thought is
um
not too long ago my youngest sister
who's 11 years younger than me she
turned 20.
and
i remember having this moment talking to
her on her 20th birthday being like
so um at this time of
my life i went to prison okay
don't go to italy
well that's the thing though it happens
everywhere yeah it's not like it's just
this special thing about italy i um
i didn't really know that wrongful
convictions were a thing until i came
home and i interacted with other people
who were wrongly convicted
um
but so i definitely felt like it's an
italy thing but no it's not what is the
is it comforting to meet people like
that and is it is it kind of like a
support group for people who have gone
through that it is tremendously
comforting in a way that is really hard
to explain
um
it's it's so comforting
that
the you sort of love
these people
without even needing to know them there
is amongst exonerees
an incredible amount of
just sort of immediate familial
familiarity and love and support
that is just like automatic we have this
sort of fundamental understanding and
experience that is difficult
to convey to other people what it felt
like
yeah bad so do you have regrets and how
do you deal with that like regrets about
i know you were 20 i mean you were a kid
um do you forgive yourself for
any of the missteps that that
you took and and um
during your interrogation let's say or
yeah i struggled with my interrogation
for a long time i felt like
what my interrogation
revealed was that i was a weak coward
like as much as i didn't understand what
was happening to me somehow what had
happened was my fault my italian wasn't
good enough or i just didn't remember
the night well enough to make it
understood to them and so i beat myself
up a lot as hard as it was to hear a
guilty verdict the worst absolute worst
part of my experience like if i were to
distill it to one moment was being
interrogated i have never been more
scared and more confused in my entire
life
the way that they broke me down made me
feel like i was crazy that i couldn't i
couldn't trust question reality create
question myself question my own memory
that was by the book
and there was nothing unique
or special about
my experience
it was just one of the same
ongoing problem
and
it was comforting because i realized
that one i'm not the only person that
this has ever happened to
and two
that
this was a systematic problem it wasn't
a me problem
and that allowed me to
heal
you know i i look back on my 20 year old
self and i feel a lot i don't feel shame
for her
i feel
sadness and i feel pity for what she was
put through
well i do too i mean
yeah i mean i agree
what was it like talking to malcolm
gladwell and
how did he respond to your disagreement
with what he wrote malcolm reached out
to me
because he was writing this book and he
wanted to use audio from my memoir
to supplement his audiobook that was how
he reached out to me that's how i found
out that he was doing a book he didn't
like interview me or talk to me
he just sort of like you know absorbed
materials from around the way read my
memoir
and decided to write a chapter of the
book about it
and i was like well wow i'm getting
malcolm gladwell and then i said
malcolm gladwell can i malcolm gladwell
you
and
i invited him on to you know talk about
his obsessions and his you know his
writing obsessions i asked to read his
chapter before he put it out into the
world i was just like i'm not going to
tell you to change it or anything but i
just want to read it i mean he was like
yeah absolutely here you go and i
disagreed with him and i sent him
my disagreements and he said well i hear
you but it'll all make sense in the
context of my book and i was like okay
um and then i read his book and i was
like i still don't think it actually
made sense in the content but whatever
it's fine
yeah well that must be strange too
somebody that you admire and certainly
respect changing your truth or or
however you um it's you i mean it was
your behavior like you know how you were
feeling in that in those moments and in
the context of his book he was trying to
make a point about something else that
yeah people being able to read one
another
and the reason why i even pushed him on
it was that he sort of made this
statement about wrongful convictions
towards the end where he was like well
maybe the kinds of people who get
wrongfully convicted are innocent people
who act guilty
and that was sort of like the like the
takeaway of that chapter is there are
certain people in the world who don't
act like we expect them to
and therefore those are the type of
people who get wrongfully convicted and
my objection to that is that is doing
that same thing of thinking oh there are
other people unlike me who get wrongly
convicted and my sort of pushback
against him is
you don't have to be a guilty
acting innocent person to be perceived
as acting guilty like who is actually
judging the way you are acting is going
like the lens through which they are
viewing you which is through suspicion
is going to color
their perception of your actions so no
matter who you are and what you're doing
someone is going to be able to find
fault in it and that is where
the disconnect is i now i'm now thinking
about your um the section about you in
that book which is like now strikes me
as being very
cherry-picking and and similar in a way
to what the detectives did that
detective did um
trying to create this narrative
trying to make something fit
yeah our human ability to see what we
want to see
is universal and we see that across the
board
every day we we see each other doing
that exact same thing seeing what we
want to see
and i think we would all do well
to be aware that we're naturally prone
to that and to sort of
step back and go am i seeing what i want
to see or am i seeing reality
i don't think we're very good at doing
that
and that's one of those sort of silver
lining things for me
is
i now sort of approach situations and
constantly have this sort of reflex of
like
am i seeing what i want to see are those
people seeing what they want to see what
are we actually looking at yo you must
be you you must have a much more honed
sense of that you must have a
much uh
clearer sense of that and and more
empathetic i imagine
more compassionate
i mean i just i it just i have a a now a
sort of radar
that is constantly on that sort of
searching for examples of when someone
is becoming an idea of a person as
opposed to a person or when somebody
like when an idea is circulating that is
a compelling idea but maybe not an
evidence-based idea like these are all
things that i'm just sort of alerted to
because they have impacted me so
personally but i also understand
how if that's not if something like that
hasn't impacted you personally
then why would you ever look for it why
would you uh you don't have the same
radar well
well i was thinking it's funny i was
thinking when i was watching the
documentary i there's a uh when when you
are acquitted uh not not the final time
you're acquitted but when you're still
in italy and you're allowed to go home
there were hordes of people outside the
courthouse screaming in protest about
the
verdict and it felt very similar to um
the thing that just happened at the
capitol which is like a bunch of people
believed a lie
um
how how did you feel about it at the
time and how are you now able to look
back at that and um
intellectualize it if you can
oh i mean the only way to to do anything
with it is to and intellectualize that
yeah that's the only
safe way to approach it because
if i approach it from a place of you
know wow that's a really personal thing
to me i just feel sad um but like if i
want to genuinely
gain some sort of knowledge or or
anything good out of it i just have to
intellectualize it
my experience of leaving the courtroom
was not being like walking out of the
courtroom into a crowd of people
screaming shame shame at me like that
was not my experience my experience was
being utterly shocked because again like
i had lost faith that the truth mattered
so i wasn't expecting an acquittal
and
so i'm like being
basically carried out of the courtroom
by my prison guards who are trying to
console me because they think that i
didn't understand the verdict they're
telling me no no you won and i'm like i
know
like they thought that i didn't
understand because i was hysterical and
oh my god and a few of them were like
good job amanda i won like 20 bucks
because they were like betting on me
oh my god and then like and then i go
from instead of being put into the
regular prison van which is this like
windowless van that i'm normally put in
they put me in the back of a police car
that has windows and suddenly i'm
exposed to
this like i can see from the car window
the street and like and that just being
able to see the street out of a car
window
after like i literally was just in a
prison then in a prison van box and then
a courtroom that was all i saw
for four years and then like i just see
like a street with regular people on it
and i was just i was so overwhelmed just
from that
super sensory overload i didn't like
sleep for a week
after that because i was i couldn't eat
for a week and i couldn't sleep for a
week i was just like
high and um
and just adrenaline rushed because here
i am
also like getting on a plane suddenly
and being put into like an airport with
hundreds of people and camera like it
was so overwhelming i had been for four
years only exposed to my family members
for an hour at a time at most
and so suddenly i'm hanging out with my
my little cousins who are running around
who i haven't seen since they were
literally babies and i'm i'm just
overwhelmed that's the only thing i can
say is like adrenaline rush overwhelmed
was there a paranoia that like oh my god
this could go away going to an italian
restaurant and hearing that accent and
like i mean were you being triggered by
other stimuli so i was being triggered
for
god at least a year afterwards
i couldn't be around crowds of people
um i couldn't be
i remember i was invited to this um
italian film festival
um
and
and i went because i was like i'm trying
to be supportive and and you know i
don't hate italian people because of
what i went through so i went
but
there was a moment during the film where
a person in the film said a word that i
had only ever heard in prison
and it was a facity which i heard a lot
in prison because a fochity means
um you know come like basically show
your face
and it's their way of saying like come
to the cell door i need to talk to you
usually like the guards are saying that
or someone else in the prison is like
hey i need to talk to you a facility
come to the cell door
and
in real life what people use that to say
is like hey i'm outside come to the
window i want to talk to you or come to
the door
and i had only only only ever heard this
in prison and so when i heard the
character say hey a fatih
i had a panic attack like right there in
the middle of the movie theater i was
like i need to leave i need to leave i
need to leave
um
so
you know
it's still even now like when i
encounter people and i hear italian like
i'm still fluent and i can understand
italian
um i do get a moment of like
oh my god uh
are they talking about me no okay we're
okay
or like i can't believe you went to a
a film festival because just i you must
be if i were you i would imagine you'd
be so triggered by those long lens
paparazzi and the paparazzi were
disgusting i mean i went through a
period around that time where i was like
oh they're annoying whatever but i i i
can't imagine
how you must feel about those people the
people that like
climb over walls to spy into the
constant like in the courtroom and like
that was revealing how are you around
cameras
i get very very nervous around cameras
um
and i
thankfully now my i have a husband
around who i like automatically just
hide behind if i see a camera out um
going to new york is interesting because
people have their cameras out everything
every like there's all these beautiful
things that you can photograph and i'm
just constantly a little paranoid
whenever i'm in new york because i'm
like
like just
just the technological change of
everyone having a camera now i imagine
traveling anywhere it's like you have a
very recognizable face
and it must get that must get tiresome
it's weird i i it still sort of boggles
my mind when
like during the pandemic even i traveled
down
to i think it was maybe santa fe
no it was la it was la because i went on
whitney cummings podcast
i walked out of the of the airport with
my mask on i had told no one that i was
coming and there were paparazzi out
there and they were like amanda amanda
and i was just like
how did you know that i was like this i
i have a mask well the people on the
planes there are a couple that are worse
than others but they
it's the people who work at the airlines
it's i mean i guess that's capitalism
but it's horrible and
i i really really wish there were actual
better protections because i don't think
you can make
a claim
that me going to la
is in the public interest anymore
i'm no longer on trial i am literally
just doing uh i'm a podcaster like how
is that true well i guess you can argue
that well podcasts are entertainment
therefore you're an entertainer
but even then it's like okay why does
being an entertainer
mean that my private life is now in the
public interest just because it might be
entertaining to someone doesn't mean
that it is in their interest to know
so yes i agree i'm putting the devil in
devil's advocate um
who else has been on your podcast it's
called labyrinths and where people can
find it anywhere right anywhere um and
it we've had such a great we we're good
we're so lucky with season one we got
andrew yang who i know that you're a
you're a sanders fan
um basically i really like andrew yang
yeah i'm i'm a big andrew yang fan i
think universal basic income is the
struggle that needs to happen right now
because i think even just sort of
imagining a world where we're still
being
judged and measured and valued based
upon
our productivity levels doesn't make
sense anymore because we simply don't
work in the world and have value and
productivity in the world like we used
to
so
having conversations about minimum wage
seem
like
decades-old conversations that should
have been dealt with decades ago and now
we need to be having the universal basic
income so anyway andrew yang and malcolm
gladwell and levar burton
and this is so cool and you know this
were you a reading rainbow fan reading
rainbow fan star trek huge fan
um
yeah i'm a huge fan and you know he's
definitely the most eligible bachelor on
the enterprise
did you tell him that
um i think i did tell him that
even with those glasses huh oh
absolutely that adds intrigue you're
like what do you say that's true
that's true that's true how many eyes do
you have yeah
um and you can see like my heat waves
like ooh
yeah so you were more star trek than
star wars i mean i'm a huge nerd so
i love it um i just had more crushes on
characters in star trek like i a little
bit want jean-luc picard to sort of be
my
my daddy
and
everybody you know and like i kind of
want data to just protect me and and be
my person here like this is weird
because again i'm also just a regular
person who has crushes on people that i
see on tv
like i had the biggest crush on jackie
chan when i was a kid
because he's just like so cool and he's
so funny and like he's just amazing
so
oh interesting
did you watch what and what others i'm
hung up on what you watched in prison of
all the things i could ask you what
other stuff were you i mean i know you
were reading a lot but what
what was uh another way that you were
able to escape by watching like comedies
there was only one show that i liked to
watch on tv in prison and that was
largely because i didn't really actually
have control of my tv it was
the other prisoners were the ones who
i hope it wasn't oz no absolutely not no
it was incredible it was only on very
very late night on the one sort of like
odd channel that you wouldn't think
would be in prison but it was mtv we had
mtv italia in prison and very very late
at night they would do flight of the
concords and i watched light of the
concords and it was bizarre because they
didn't actually dub it it was just in
english and so it was like the only
person who could appreciate that show
was me
and that was the one show that i watched
other people were watching soap operas
all the time and so a lot of times i was
doing
being exposed to that isn't it funny
that like people are watching and then
you were kind of a soap opera you were a
player in this like
so it was a real soap opera yes yeah
yeah if people have not seen the movie
is that the one you would recommend i
know there are a lot of things about the
trial and about your experience but uh
the one i saw was the netflix movie i
think it's just amanda knox yes it's
just called amanda knox um i think that
those the filmmakers of that documentary
did a really good job
um they had incredible access to people
and i think the thing that they did
successfully that i try to do in my own
journalism today
is they
gave people the opportunity not just to
describe what they did and what happened
but what they think about what they did
yes
exactly exactly they kept it going on
they kept the camera they added a little
bit of footage at the tail end even if
it was like a second of a self-satisfied
smile by the journalist or the
prosecutor
it spoke volumes about how they
felt yes about their participation and
and that helps tell this story i mean to
me it was so
clear i mean if anyone listening is like
yeah but did she do it i mean
watch this thing and it's like
funnily enough a number of people have
seen the film
or have seen the documentary and go
i don't know though she still just seems
a little off to me like i've had people
say that to me so
again you see what you want to see
right people say this on social media is
that where you're consuming most of that
is on social media where i'm exposed to
it um but it also is a reflection of
like even the kinds of you know people
who reach out to me to talk to me like
there are some people in the world who
have just written me off as a human
being like and not even as like you're a
guilty person i'm not going to talk to
you but like you're a tabloid person the
only place i've ever been exposed to is
the tabloids so you must be a tabloid
person
and it's frustrating because it's like
well actually i never i don't do tabloid
stuff like that's not my thing
so i actually feel really like blessed
and and grateful when somebody wants to
have a not doesn't treat me that way so
thank you yeah
well well you um yeah also
my heart breaks for your experience and
and again like i i think
just selfishly too i
i think a lot of people can recognize
um
the the potential for
their own experiences and what you went
through and their own nightmare that
they could go through that anyone could
go through this yeah and it could happen
like that
like you don't have to do anything you
like it just can happen like that do you
ever look at your life as being pre
italy and and post i mean is that how
you've kind of
how do you see those periods of your
life do you ever do you look at it that
way well i mean it also happened at this
like crucial juncture in my life where i
went from being a child to an adult
so
there's me being a child a young person
an innocent a naive
then there's prison and then there's
adulthood
how difficult too amanda was it that you
touched on this earlier and i i this was
part of the misogyny that i recognized
was how your sex life had become this
thing that was part of stories part of
headline stories and like when you said
the number of like partners you had i i
thought well [ __ ] when i was 20 21 i'd
had that many partners and like i got
started late i was like a late bloomer
with that stuff me too
yeah yeah so like that didn't strike me
as like a crazy number not by any means
i related to that and and i also would
have been
super embarrassed if people knew that if
like my mother knew that you know
what was that like having that
plastered everywhere
um
well it definitely
so when your life is on the line and
your future is on the line
your sort of embarrassment about your
sex life becomes secondary at that point
like again you know in the same way that
like shawshank redemption that guy was
willing to drop all of his dignity and
climb through [ __ ] to get out of a
terrible situation
if it were the case that like i had to
do you know the cersei you know walking
naked through the city while being
thrown food at just to like
get home
i would have got like i don't give a sh
wow i will i will go through anything
there's a desperation and there's also
like
your freedom
that is stripped from you
unfairly
puts everything else into perspective
and everything else becomes secondary
now granted
that didn't mean that i was was like
sitting there in court going oh my god
why are we talking about my sex life
this is about my roommate who was raped
and murdered by a guy who broke into our
house like what does my sex life have to
do with anything right so there was that
frustration of feeling like well it's
frustration because it's like we're
we're veering so far away from what is
actually at stake here which is a young
what a weird smoke screen exactly yeah
life could be a dream sweetheart
hello hello
[Music]
when you do re-interest society how what
is your zihuatanejo where when did you
find like that peace that that um are
you there now is that the island that
you live on
i mean i found a lot of peace um
actually when i first met my husband um
because i i met him under
um what were unusual circumstances for
me so when i first came home i did not
like to talk like i did not like meeting
new people i didn't try i didn't trust
anyone i was very isolated and i also
felt really concerned because people
paparazzi were following me so if you
were my friend then you were going to be
exposed to that kind of treatment and
people would read and you would end up
on it on a you know daily mail headline
and that was not something that i liked
exposing people to and i felt constantly
spotlet and and um isolated because of
that
um but then like very very shortly after
i was fully definitively acquitted by
the the italian supreme court i
interviewed my hus my future husband um
but some dude that i didn't know to be a
husband was it like a it was like a
husband interview
no like i i'm seeing applicants
no absolutely not because it was not on
my radar to be intimate with anyone that
i didn't know
it was just out of the question
and so what was it for what was the
interview for i was doing local
correspondence um under an anonymous
name
um of like arts like arts in the local
community so i would go to plays and
might write reviews and i would read
books and i i read his book he
published his debut novel
and i happened to
stumble across his book reading and
normally this is not something that i
would go to because it involved
strangers in a room so i would never go
but this time i was like you know what
i'll just kind of sneak in and try to be
invisible and you know i saw his photo
no i didn't see it saw that northwestern
northwestern man
um actually like when i remember when i
first saw him i was like he had like
stripes um
carved into his beard
and he had this sort of like eccentric
style where i was like oh it's
it's very like a modern-day elton john
kind of vibe going from the sky
hopefully not that much like elton john
i mean it wasn't a sparkly for sure but
i
i came away like in indeed like i asked
him for an interview and so he invited
me to come over to his house and i you
know we did a very official interview
but that sort of devolved into drinking
scotch and watching star trek and at the
very end of that oh boy i know where
this is headed
yeah but at the very end of it he was
just like hey we should be friends
and
i was just like oh my god
i can make friends with people now yeah
wow
it struck me and that's when i was first
starting to feel a little bit safer in
the world that's cool was he amanda did
he know
who you were i mean was he like oh you
hey you're a man of knox and you write
for this thing did he have a an idea of
who you were he knew my name um he was
aware that i was involved in some kind
of true crime situation but he was like
a poetry guy like in the middle of all
of this he had his nose like deep in
elizabeth bishop and he was not
the the poet
poet the
right and she wouldn't she wouldn't
swing his direction anyway so
that's right that's true
but
so he like he sorta kind of had heard
about it but he thought it had something
to do with defenestration like he had no
idea
so that's good which was great because
he just sort of decided not to google me
and instead just kind of got to know me
from hanging out
and of course i would sort of bring up
occasional anecdotes like he'd be like
oh man have you seen the movie wall-e
and i was like no i haven't seen them
he's like how could you not see that and
i was like when did it come out
i was in prison
yeah what movies did you when you got
out not movies but just anything that
had happened in society in seattle while
you were away what were the things that
most struck you or are you just so
relieved to be
free that you're like ah whatever
everything pales in comparison to being
able to see the sky and go to the beach
oh yeah i'm i'm i do not like regret
having missed anything because again
it's more like thank god i'm out um but
like you know i missed the whole like
obama
getting elected first black president um
i missed i missed the whole rise of
justin bieber i didn't know who he was
wow well that's you didn't miss that
much
you missed die hard four um what uh
um
did you ever get financial compensation
from italy from
no okay
that's a beautiful thing that we do
better here in the in i mean it depends
on what state you have here in the
united states but um the the interesting
thing about um wrongful conviction
compensation is there are so many
loopholes that um
that
the bureaucracy of criminal justice has
put into that to find reasons not to
compensate people for wrongful
conviction and they'll like say
well because you acted suspicious the
police were justified and wrongly
convicted
so god so you know
i'm not ever expecting to be compensated
from italy um i'm just having to make my
own way and do the best i can
and what about meredith's
what about her family the kirchers are
they like did have they ever made any
overtures to be like we believe you or
do they still believe that you did it
so i don't i can't speak to what they
believe today i know that they
haven't made any gestures to reach out
to me and i do know that meredith's
father who's
since passed published a book
about the case in which he very very
blatantly
feels that i am guilty but again like he
wrote that years ago
um i don't know
i cannot speak to how they feel today
it's sort of an ongoing struggle for me
of wanting to
connect with them but also understanding
that of all the people in the world who
might trigger them
yeah that's me
through no yeah well that's the irony
yeah the irony is that you are now have
a heightened sensitivity to
other people's triggers and
um
because of what you went through so
i mean that's
admirable of you i i i
and that's also like the irony with that
is that a lot of people accuse me of
being incredibly
um
ungracious and unthoughtful towards them
because i dare to exist in any kind of
public way like it their sort of view is
that if i really cared about the kercher
family i would disappear from existence
yeah
and i wouldn't talk about my experience
being wrongly convicted because that is
sort of
a traumatizing thing for them and it's
and it's this idea that like
whatever i went through
pales in comparison to what they went
through so i should just disappear
and i've never been in the business of
trying to compare
traumas once the paparazzi subsided or
maybe it hadn't yet but what what was
the moment where you felt like you could
breathe and you could really like exist
again in this in in freedom in the world
um did you catch yourself like enjoying
a moment of peace or like listening to a
song or like laughing at a movie and you
were like oh [ __ ] i forgot my ordeal
what what did you feel like you you
started forgetting
i definitely was impacted by
smell
of home when i first came home so
and like being exposed to nature again
so um
maybe like a month after i got home
um a friend took me mushroom hunting and
feeling i almost felt like i was walking
on the moon because the earth was so
soft it wasn't this concrete that i'd
been used to walking on for four years
so being
on in like the quiet of nature
bouncing like just
glowing bouncing on this like soft earth
was extraordinary and very very
therapeutic so
come home with like a huge basket of
mushrooms and turn that into so much
risotto it's great oh how cool now you
still you still eat italian food wow oh
yeah i still go mushroom hunting and
make risotto absolutely
wow
they're not going to take that from me
um what is your
what is your most commonly used emoji
would you say amanda or do you use
emojis
i don't often use emojis but i think
maybe thumbs up i don't speak through
emoji all that often
well you're articulate so you don't need
to um if you could be a professional
athlete what sport would you play oh so
what would i do potentially in real life
i used to play soccer so i probably
would have done soccer if i became one
but really
what i would want to be as a
professional athlete a fantasy my
fantasy would be um a lindy hop like
competitive dancer
lindy hop i'm picturing somebody
actually hopping but i know that's not
it like no it's a swing dance so it's
really awesome swing dance i actually do
do lindy hop but i am in no way
professional at all
um
oh yeah they have competitions actually
you know what after this
look up like
you know lindy hop competitions there's
some wild
fun dancing that people do i will
yeah i'll look it up actually right
after
i subscribe to labyrinth
if you could have one snack food for the
rest of your life what would it be
jeez wow really yeah i thought all these
things would be triggering okay
i mean i did not get any barata in
prison
that's true that's true i was just about
to say that like i'm sure the prison
food is not like just because it's
italian doesn't mean it's good no no no
uh
wow wow was it just standard
what was it like cafeteria food um i
mean it was just like a lot of pasta
like it was just a lot of boiled pasta
um
and
yeah just you know just like scraps of
things um
yeah the food wasn't great uh
um parents bring you food could they
smuggle stuff in
um so they were allowed to bring me
certain kinds of food and they did
because especially my stepdad who was
able to spend more time there than
anyone else in my family he's an i.t guy
so he could do his work from abroad
he his love language is food so he found
all these ways to smuggle in things that
normally i wouldn't be able to have
like on thanksgiving he was really
intent on getting me cranberry sauce
um and i there was no way that they were
going to let in cranberry sauce you
could like hide drugs in it so
usually it's like solid foods that they
allow you to bring in and they're like
in you know store-bought containers well
he
froze some cranberry sauce so by the
time it arrived to the prison it was
solid but by the time it arrived to me
it was sauce again it's amazing oh how
sweet what is your favorite movie sequel
of all time
i mean maybe um
harry potter and the prisoner of azkaban
okay i've never you know i've never seen
any of them
you are in for a treat my friend read
the books yeah first what's your go-to
carry do you ever seen karaoke because i
imagine you go in the private room so
you have to do it in front of everyone
but do you ever do that um i love to do
karaoke and i really really like to do
either
zombie by the cranberries oh cranberries
yeah yeah or rolling in the deep by
adele
oh great yeah oh god i love the
cranberries a lot of cranberry talk all
of a sudden really oh yeah cranberries
who else are you sauce
about
it's funny our next our next question is
uh who was your first celebrity crush
but i had such a crush on dolores
riordan um
who was sure for a celebrity crush
probably jackie chan oh yeah that's
right that's right
wow that's so
interesting you know apparently he is um
he's a very hardcore he's not your type
no no no no he uh i no i think he's
impressive as hell oh no i think he's
incredible oh god his like physical
prowess um is amazing the fact that he
can make
fighting fun and like his ability to do
drama and comedy like i just found him
to be
an all-around awesome guy and i really
liked his personality and i i don't know
i like fun people what is your uh if you
do have a tattoo and and
uh if not would you consider getting one
oh you do have many a tattoo oh okay all
right and
i don't know i mean i can i can show you
well
i'm wondering what um were these all
post italy
yes uh one of them i had prior to italy
but most of them i got afterwards and
one of them is directly in reference to
everything that happened in italy oh
what's that what's that i have an italy
tattoo um so it's my biggest tattoo it's
all on my side here um and it is a lamb
that is in um
this like triumphant griffin position
that normally like the the symbol of
perugia is a griffin in this like uh
triumphant position like on its rear leg
sort of rearing
the yeah and i put that i put the lamb
there
with some olive branches
um to symbolize um the lamb that wasn't
slaughtered so
the sacrificial lamb that survived and
survived
that's cool what a great yeah wow that's
hard to beat that
have you thought about getting any more
so again i have a bunch um my husband
and i have a bunch of shared tattoos um
and the ones that are most directly
relevant to our work are on our forearms
as kind of reminders
so um i have a bunch of symbols on my
arm that have to do with like compassion
and being willing to change
um and you know being open like always
sort of viewing the other person's
perspective from the in the best light
possible not trying to find fault in
things but trying to understand it from
you know its best place
um and also being very aware that like
this symbol the skepticism's hey i don't
know if you can see it but it's um it's
a
a resistor symbol from electrical
engineering and and what that signifies
to me is a kind of skepticism
and not just what kind of energy and
information i'm taking in but also in
what kind of energy and information i'm
putting out into the world being aware
that like i'm responsible for
the kinds of things that i'm allowing to
impact me and also the kinds of things
that i am
potentially impacting other people oh
that's great i love that i know i look
back on the one that i had prior to
italy and i go wow i wouldn't get that
same tattoo today it's like a chakra but
it's also kind of an important reminder
of who i was back then totally yes yeah
you were a chakra tattoo girl i was a
chakra yoga girl so yeah what is your
favorite fruit if you could have like
the perfect piece of like it's perfectly
ripe
what fruit in your fantasy
hmm raspberry and who would you want to
play you in uh in the biopic in in the
amanda knox story
i would not want there to be a biopic
okay okay there already are a bunch
all right okay i can't ask you this
question it'd be fun to do one though
where it has nothing to do with your uh
the italian uh part of your life that
would be interesting yeah um at which
point i'd have to reflect because i've
mostly sort of dreaded the idea of yet
another biopic coming out about me so
i'll have to think about that
all right we we asked everyone that but
i have to i should have thought about
that um what's your favorite who's your
favorite simpsons character that's hard
um
i mean i love apu
i also
find mr burns to be hilarious
oh my god
of course funny um yeah
and the like cruella de vil version of
him with c my vest see my vest
made of real gorilla chest i really like
the vest
yes i gathered
that's that's my favorite part of that
is at the end of it
he has that exchange with smithers where
he's like i really like the best like
the best and he's like i know sir
that's
so good
yeah oh no i love monty burns i love
when he goes to bunt in the uh when he
gets all the ringers for the baseball
team and he just flies straight back
yeah he's great
yeah um who what about dogs or cats
which do you prefer so i love animals
i'm a huge animal person i have three
cats
my husband is less of a dog person
because he feels like dogs don't
understand consent
um especially when it comes to his
crotch so
yeah that's true i agree with him yeah
but like i don't really care
yeah i have very little boundaries with
animals and kids it's like whatever pull
my hair do stick your finger up my nose
like i don't care yeah yeah he has more
boundaries than i do okay well we're
almost done beetles are the rolling
stones
i mean i think the beatles are more
versatile
um i do love me a rolling stone song but
i think i've listened to more beatles in
my time
especially since i can like sing them um
i can play guitar oh cool
uh
cool what what were you able to listen
to music in prison
so i had a little um cd player i was
allowed a certain number like three cds
at a time
i definitely remember grooving um to the
xx
like i would just like bed and um listen
to the xx album over and over and over
again and sort of like sadly
touch
like that i had a few pictures of my
family members and so i would sort of
lay them out on my bed in front of me
and sort of like just touch them
oh man it doesn't get more emo than
it's very emo like it's the only way to
listen to xx really yeah hopefully not
the only way um
seinfeld or uh you're watching tv and
seinfeld and friends are both on which
do you watch oh seinfeld a million times
yeah over friends oh yeah
and this is like knowing that my my
sister is a huge friends fan but like
seinfeld is just out of this world good
writing and hilarious and the way that
the
the through lines of all the episodes
come together in this like so satisfying
it's like a work of art to me i i i
some of those yeah they're constructed
in a way you know sometimes people like
i've heard people describe mathematical
equations that way like there are
they're beautiful i feel that way about
seinfeld um
yep amanda thank you i can't thank you
enough for your your just your candor
and honesty this was so
fascinating and enjoyable and um i just
admire you so much for your strength and
how you were able to come out on the
other side of all this uh and the way
you persevered that little lamb became
rose rose against all of this
well thank you so much and thanks for
having me and being a person with me
so
so that happened
chris and i were just saying because i
was hesitating i was trying to
imagine how to imitate her and he said
well why do you have to imitate her that
became a thing a thing maybe like 20
episodes ago where you had to imitate
the guests i don't know why i don't know
when i think it was somebody whose voice
obviously i loved imitating right and um
it was just an excuse to do that and
then he has a nice voice but it's not um
one that's super fun to imitate no and
for me because i have a deeper voice it
is harder for me to do
uh unless it's like truman capote who is
like if you clear higher voice you know
her it's harder for me to do women
in general yeah yeah i hope people
didn't just listen to that one sentence
that's the sound by mentoring the show
um
how
fascinating right yeah you know it's
funny like watching the documentary i
was
so convinced of her innocence but
hearing from her in this in this format
it she's like
the least sinister i know um she's like
the least capable sounding person
of being accused of some of such a thing
it's like she's like a sweet bookish
she's like a nerdy
self-proclaimed nerdy
sweet like kind of
down-to-earth did you just get nervous
that you had called her a nerd and like
no because she called herself no i know
i know but that's why you had to like
qualify it self-proclaimed well i have
to qualify yeah yeah i want to call
someone a nerd especially after what
she's been through she's nervous she's
just some nerd no but she's a nerd she's
like extremely intelligent and well read
and she has she's well-rounded she goes
mushroom hunting she loves
karaoke she's a really interesting
person i i would like to and i don't
know if do we we talked about this uh
hang out with her and her husband out in
the pacific north go mushroom hunting
she sounds like a really funny i'd like
to get into mushroom
knowledge me too you don't bother want
to get into mushroom knowledge um what
do they call it they call it something
funny sounding uh
but every time i see a mushroom out in
the woods like whenever i go i think i
wish i knew i want to eat it i want to
like know i want to be able to go out
and forage
yeah i'd like to see you forged for
mushrooms a little bath you know we told
when we told our mother that um we were
going to be doing this episode her
initial reaction was
oh which is a reaction that a lot of
people might have if they don't know her
whole story it's a reaction that
i to be honest i had when it was first
presented to me
because
all i remember was the completely unfair
i know media story i know that was
concocted about her the media never
accurately told the story i know it was
and now i'm like kind of embarrassed
i mean too that i me too i bought into
it i just bought into it without doing
any
research i know and there are obviously
countless examples of of that now and
you know there's so many stories of
injustice that are that are having a
light shine on them um and now
especially because i you know people are
just more aware of of things like that
because of social media because of uh
streamings or all of these uh platforms
on which to expose those injustices but
uh back then
despite all the coverage that that's the
crazy thing all the coverage that it was
getting the truth of it was so buried
beneath all these salacious
um unnecessary
inappropriate details and how how uh sex
is the whole thing oh my god she was
painted as like a [ __ ] i know
and that's the other thing that like i
still had that there were remnants of
that i didn't know from because it was
so dry i was so exposed to it and didn't
bother to do the research and eat
talking to it that's why it was so
shocking to
to to to actually talk with her and and
hear and see and feel how
not that person she was she's like a
harry potter fan she she could be
friends with ginny
um yeah i know and now i'm thinking of
like the two of them talking about like
what are you are you a fluffernutter or
a hufflepuffer
about like
what harry potter they'd be best friends
oh yeah yeah in fact i should set them
up
friend on a friend
ship uh when she was going over her
ordeals
what she went through this harrowing
story
you got so moany
um you're like oh god oh well don't i
get like that when i watch those
documents yes
you get very moany and i understand you
were moved by and captivated by it so
but it was very moany oh it wasn't oh
god it wasn't sexual sound it wasn't
sexual but no i know it wasn't not it
wasn't for me not all moans are sexual i
know but did it sound there's like
spooky ghost modes aren't sexual
[Music]
what if that's how your sexual moan is
oh
like the guy who sings the monster mash
the monster i'm about to ejaculate oh
god i'm sorry we gotta cut that out
right i don't think so maybe
because we're gonna offend that one guy
who sings the monster who does sing the
monster match doesn't she make it
impossible to ever like feel like you
can complain about anything in your life
yes yes but it's interesting to me that
she
decided to
re-enter the public life in some way
even by having a podcast and you guys
talked about the difference between uh
you know actors who she said that actors
don't really ask for that but i disagree
i think
when you go into that industry yeah
there's potential for that respect that
your personal life is going to be
that's what goes to some degree that's
what i meant that there was a potential
that there had to be i mean you've got
to be you know blind tonight
but she
had zero right desire to have that but
now she does she has a podcast right and
um
but then when she talked about it i
realized that
when she first became famous she had no
choice
and now
she's choosing to do this so it's almost
like she's taking the power back
yeah she kind of says that doesn't she
that like now she's able to
she has a
voice where whereas like that that was
the most frightening the part of her
ordeal that i never really appreciated
definitely didn't appreciate was that
she lost her
her agency and her voice i mean even
that freedom the freedom to express your
truth was taken away from her and that i
can't imagine at one point she said her
hus when she met her husband uh she said
he was like a modern day elton john and
you said
you said well i hope not that much like
elton john and she said um
he wasn't as sparkly as elton john but i
don't think she
understood what you were saying
really made me laugh well there's
nothing wrong with that if he is like
him in that way
uh anything wrong with having a
absolutely not i love elton john yeah
her um the sport that she would play if
oh i know you're gonna love this
i would i would bet that's nerdier than
i would bet almost all my money um the
fact that no one will ever
say that again
as their favorite sport yeah unless we
have um
someone who participates in is known for
that sport that one thing alone should
be enough proof that you need to know
that you would never be able to commit
this kind of crime what's it called
again like lindy hop in competitive
dancing
yeah i don't think there's ever been a
lindy hop murderer a murderer like the
venn diagram of lindy hop uh enthusiasts
and murderers
i don't think they don't connect they
don't get kinky no they're two different
circles
like i wonder if they introduced that
offense that they were laughing about
this the thing itself
obviously made those videos saying the
murder itself is so horrific and like
what that family had to go through is
awful but right now we're discussing
yeah amanda you know yeah no but i think
we should clarify that we're not
laughing at the event of course not um
no no no i mean we're laughing at lindy
hopping
yes we're laughing maybe we should maybe
the lindy hop enthusiast listeners
will be offended by us laughing at it we
shouldn't swing dancing is cool
yeah no i know but like as a sport it's
funny to say that as a sport yes also i
don't think they would i think they also
what we're saying is also flattering in
a way to lindy hoppers
because it's a fun thing to say yeah
lindy hopping i did i wasn't that i
wasn't quite sure what it was until um i
looked it up afterwards it is like line
dancing swing dance swing dancing cool i
like swing dancing yeah i wish i could
do it
yeah i i i would never have thought of
it as a sport um but
there's there you go it's like it's
active it's more of a sport than golf
and act like active wise
i don't know about that
golf is clearly a sport more murderers
more golf murders that's for sure yeah
let's read it okay
could you just feel it petering
okay this is a letter
from ronnie marsh
ronnie spelled um is that the female
spelling not that there's a difference
but r-o-n-n-i
how did uh ronnie and jersey shore spell
his name running the rhino yeah
r-o-n-n-i-e what if ronnie the rhino was
listening
i hope so i you know i saw ronnie once i
told you this right at the gym at the
gym you told me that he was surprisingly
short he was huge
like he looked like surprised by that
he's like as wide as he is tall yes he
had a rhino build he really did
um
okay this subject is my mom
justin i love listening to your podcast
thank you ronnie i think you are very
funny thank you ronnie i'm writing to
you because i think you should totally
date
have you read this yeah
you should totally date my mom
okay no
it's very sweet thank you i don't mean
to laugh i
i'm fit you're just surprised i'm
surprised i'm laughing again
it's very sweet it's very flattering
you imagine wanting i don't know
if i've ever thought that about any i
mean like our parents are still married
it's hard to imagine you wanting your
mom to date anybody anybody yeah yeah
it's a very flat she's been dating our
father for
47 years
okay back to ronnie i'm 15 and wanted to
tell you a little bit about my mom okay
thanks ronnie
she's 36 and has two kids me and my
younger sister you guys both have a lot
in common
it's hard to get through this because
i'm gonna cry this is so this is such a
sweet it is sweet isn't it really like
flattering that
it's really nice how much he loves his
mom
i think he might be like that a lot it
might be a
girl
or she is she yeah either way it's nice
so nice
okay back to ronnie um and back to her
selling me on her mom
she excuse me she is very down to earth
loves to laugh and have fun oh she
doesn't care about money she has a job i
love by the way ronnie all of these
things are so great what a great way to
like sell somebody she has a job okay
bought a house a couple years ago and
takes care of me and my sister by
herself
this is this is so great she's our
biggest cheerleader and is always there
to support us she always has our backs
and she is the same way with everyone in
her life
this is the goal in life to raise a
child who thinks this of you isn't it
i think so oh my god it's a goal yeah
yeah it's vegal it's not big but it's
what a great thing okay back to ronnie
she's not perfect by any means and not
who is ronnie she's not the best cook
lol that's okay you've got to be a
pretty good cook yes i can i can make up
for that
but i don't think she really knows how
great she is oh at least we think so
anyway she is goofy and weird and we
wouldn't change her she loves to learn
new things and is happy with the simple
things in life she gets excited over the
dumbest stuff
hey occasionally
[Music]
i also like that she thinks this of me
that she thinks i would respond to this
which she's right too and uh back to
ronnie and is perfectly happy spending
the evening watching a movie with us
she's naturally loud
i can always tell which one is my mom
when i'm playing soccer lol i really
think that you would hit it off with her
i've included a picture of her just in
case you are curious her name is melissa
ptw
thanks ronnie and there's a picture that
i can't see because it just says pasted
graphic have you seen oh yeah not that
it matters but um i am curious because
all of this no i don't i don't have it
i'll show you i'll show you when we get
you know what it shouldn't matter um she
sounds like uh she sounds like a real
catch ronnie and
more importantly it's so
nice it is just so great that you think
that of her all those things because
those are the best things to say about
something so you never know what happens
maybe you'll meet her one day and i
think you'd be a good stepdad i would
love you you have good stepdad potential
yeah it would be really nice i love kids
um yeah they she sounds great so ronnie
it'd also be cool to have somebody like
a step-daughter like that because she
seems or step son or stepson like like a
ronnie because you know a lot of 15 year
olds i feel like that's are at that age
where they're like embarrassed by their
parents exactly
i know i know and it's nice that ronnie
is not embarrassed the opposite the
opposite like really he's like really
like
into how cool his mom is or her mom or
her mom and recognizes um attributes
like that there's value in those things
that she doesn't care about money she
lacks laughs at dumb stuff she
you know support
all those things that she mentioned are
such nice things to value not like
she didn't mention her looks really or
like she has you know superficial things
that are like kind of gross so thanks
ronnie
and if you guys want to write in our
email address is life is short at
wondery.com
yeah if there are any other potential
step children yeah who want to um parent
truth but you don't have to be a
child
to write in no um but you can
yeah you can be an adult too i feel like
that but we don't often get letters from
no people that age and it's also cool
that some i also like that somebody who
i know i would like listen
well thanks again ronnie and thank you
to our guest amanda knox
for um being so open to telling her
story and uh what a story yeah what a
story what a
what a way to uh
make the best out of a really horrible
situation i hope you all um
who all of you who aren't as familiar
with her story or weren't as familiar
with the story i hope you
watch
that netflix movie because it is i think
she deserves to have as many people
um
know about her as possible because what
she went through is
just so
like wildly unfair that uh
i i hope there are fewer people like me
out there moving forward who were like
oh amanda knox that's right did she do
it or didn't she you know that because
that's not fair that she has to live i
know uh in that world and in general try
to um open yourself up to learning
facts of cases like this i'm talking to
myself too i'm not preaching i i i'm too
susceptible to like you know superficial
details skimming over news stories and
but there are people's lives who are uh
hanging in the balance
yes and check out her podcast
labyrinths yes great podcast i listened
to an episode it is truly good and um
as is she and we really appreciate her
coming on and we'll uh talk to y'all
next week yes thank you ronnie and thank
you everyone for listening life could be
a dream
life could be a dream
life is short is hosted by me justin
long it is co-hosted by you christian
long and it is produced by you as well
as well as one megan monaco senior
producer is michelle miesh lans we'd
also like to thank mauricio here in
sarasota at bay sound really appreciate
the use of his wonderful facilities and
our audio engineer sergio enriquez an
executive producer by the name of
marshall louis for wondering
[Music]
you can only watch one for the rest of
your life jesus that's a good question
um
wow
argh that is tough that was nerdy
basketball's fun it's quick and it's
like
i might pick basketball too i
you get some quick baskets but watching
football is so fun but you're waiting so
long
i know but it's such a like great
it's such a great like really tough like
um spectator sport because
you get to dre it's fun to go to a bar
and try if you don't be hard to never
get to do again in my life go to like an
outdoor austin bar
have a few lone stars and like watch
outdoor and watch football outside watch
like two games in a row
i'm really torn i've had so much i've
had such good memories from like
watching football games so you pick
football uh but i but it's hard because
i basketball is so much more exciting
and
it can't but football can fall is not
even an option no not for me i i really
like going to baseball games but
watching baseball on tv unless it's the
series
kind of sucks
that's like a middle-aged guy thing oh
no
you